no power in the verse can stop me so in
my going through the works of Joss
Whedon died like um I have now arrived
at Firefly and yeah that I I have done
Cape not like as a full proper cosplay
because I didn't have the the hair
correctly but I I have done it as a
cosplay it's the this has the patches I
got the bear so yeah I do enjoy Firefly
quite a bit so I'm not actually gonna do
something that I said I wasn't gonna do
again unless like the last time I did it
got something like 50,000 views or
whatever which it's getting closer to
then and I thought it would so go um but
in any case this is only a handful of
episodes in one movie so we're gonna
start off with that thing that I did for
Doctor Who which is every episode in ten
words or less now these themselves will
not suffice so much as reviews they are
just ten words to give sort of a little
bit of something about the episode maybe
it's my feeling about it maybe it's just
a joke I think is funny that actually is
not representative of my feelings at all
so we're gonna do that first because
it's quick and it's fun in this case and
then once we got that done I will
actually rank every episode of the show
with the film serenity worked into the
ranking as well so that's enough
preamble let's get into this
meet your new surrogate family it's the
first episode again but faster enjoy the
reaper build-up they won't be this scary
again we sure this isn't a hootenanny
we took space out of space western and
worth sorry dang she's good
never meet your heroes they might be
Jane only sixty percent in and you will
fear the hero dying but most of this
will pay off next season
oh wait past episode actions have
consequences and they hurt dang she's
not as good as the first time feels were
always gonna hit this episode just
carried them you thought the Malon and
our relationship was problematic before
meet the rough draft of the operative
thought on his death and Buffy was
unsatisfying hold my beer okay here we
go now let's actually do a ranking
talking these in a little bit more
detail starting at the bottom working
our way up and down we're at the bottom
we have safe safe is the episode where
they are delivering the cattle that they
picked up in shindig which was the
episode previous and basically that's
it's them in a really backwater town
even by Firefly standards and the locals
take River for a witch and try to burn
her and this episode isn't awful it's
not terrible but there is literally
nothing I like about this episode not a
single thing so like my relationship
with the the the Western elements of
this is I love western as a flavor I'm
not a big fan of it as a genre so this
episode is the most Western episode the
show of the show there is as far as I'm
concerned and I think that's a big part
of why I don't like it because it's like
we're just we're just dealing with this
backwater town with these you know
people who are who are out of step with
modern life and they're scared by a
woman who can do things they can't I got
a burner for a witch I'm like this just
it's just this isn't what I want from my
sci-fi series and like I get that the
outer planets are meant to be the Wild
West I get that I'm not arguing with
that I'm saying this makes the point too
hard this makes the point so hard that
is
and and the other stuff that's going on
in here because it's moving forward to
Kayleigh and Simon relationship are
trying to and I don't like that either
I'm not gonna dwell too much on that in
this video but future videos I'll be
covering that a little bit more and
there's just there's just nothing very
fun very entertaining there's no great
banter there's no great memorable moment
from this it just kind of is and there's
nothing I like about it that was number
15 because once it counts serenity of
the film there are 15 days total for me
to rank so next up number 14 janestown
now before going back and be watching
the series cuz I did actually do that
for this I thought this one was gonna
occupy the bottom spot cuz I remembered
not liking this one when I first saw it
I didn't remember not liking safe I
actually turned out I just had scrub
safe from my memory altogether so
there's a lot I don't like about this
episode but I'm like safe there are also
some things that I do like so those
those bring it up at least a little bit
so the stuff that I don't love I don't
think this is a particularly great
examination of Jane as a character I
don't think there's anything that we
learn about him here that we either
didn't already learn about him or
doesn't get said better in later
episodes the I've I've never been a fan
of the the misunderstood you know the
the person who leans into the
misunderstandings about them you know
whether they they set up the lie that
they now have to perpetuate or they
stumble into it but like the person who
might get found out and then does it's
just it's a boring it's a boring story
point and it's something that I I I
don't particularly care for and it's
leaned on rather heavily here and just
the whole narrative just didn't really
engage me now I did say there are some
things that I like and there are and it
mainly has to do with the very end of
the episode when Jane you know kind of
snaps and yells of these people and
pushes
the statue storms away and he's just
he's just back in serenity going I don't
understand and you know saying they're
just gonna put that statue back up
aren't they and other folks might yeah
they probably will they need to believe
in something even if that's something
when they saw it wasn't what they wanted
it to be and Jesus said I I just can't
understand it and then they're like
that's the one moment we get from him
that feels like it actually tells us a
little something about him because
there's an honesty to that moment I'm
not sure it's it's enough insight to
justify the entire rest of the episode
but that that melancholy that sets in
for him this sort of youma sense he's
having a like an existential crisis over
it that's nice it's a good final note
everybody up to that final note is if he
had best for me but had more than safe
going number 13 hearts of gold so this
one's this one's a mix honestly the
first two that I did are the only ones
that everyone's that I flat-out dislike
the next few are gonna be ones that are
very they're just mixed there are they
are a mixture of things that I do like
and things that I'm like IRA do we have
to so there is stuff that I do like in
this episode there's some great dialogue
there's some great banter between a
number of characters I like how at home
Jane is in this brothel and yet he he
doesn't come across as skeevy being with
these women he comes across as eager as
heck but he doesn't come across you know
overly possessive he doesn't come across
as as the misogynistic jerk that the
villain is so I thought that's a
surprisingly nice balance of elements
the villain getting dispatched is a
great moment I love this mother with
their newborn babies come out meet your
daddy mmm say goodbye to your daddy but
yeah that works so all that stuff is
good the action is pretty decent
I like the them prepping you know for
when they know the attacks coming but an
aren mal I don't love their relationship
in the first place
and their relationship gets really
muddied by how much he calls her a [ __ ]
like I get that part of his animosity at
least in a certain element it has to do
with he does have feelings for her and
it's easier to push her away than try
and deal with that I do understand that
but he calls her a [ __ ] literally the
very first time meteor and unless you're
gonna try and we see that in flashback
in another episode so unless you try and
tell me that he was in love with her
first sight that's not a play at the
very beginning and it makes the whole
relationship with them really annoying
and awkward and it gets dumber and weird
or in this one because Mao sleeps very
readily with the woman who runs this
brothel who Inara knows and then Inara
she has initially what I thought was a
great reaction to that which was you
know I'm John I'm surprised she lowered
her standards
it's just sex mal what's the problem I
mean which makes total sense that's her
profession and then we see her in her in
her shuttle crying and again I get I get
the idea I get the idea she put up a
front but she does have feelings for him
so of course she's hurt but
unfortunately it feeds in to this and I
don't believe this is intentional but it
feeds into this notion that oh you know
that those those sex-positive you know I
can do it all on my own I can take care
of myself women in their heart of hearts
they really are just big softies who
want a big strong man to take care of
them and they'll get their hearts broken
one day you know it's it feels like it's
feeding that narrative that at the end
of the day
a woman just wants a man and and I know
that the show intends it to be much more
about the actual connection between
these two specifically but it hasn't
been built up all enough for that moment
to read the way it's supposed to and it
it makes worse a relationship that it
was already iffy on moving up to number
12 we have shindig which does again it's
a mix of things I like him that I don't
like I kind of like the duel I kind of
like how that pans out and how that goes
I don't particularly care for the
k-league going to the you know the big
party and there's basically the Mean
Girls they're not a huge fan of that but
there are some other interactions that
are really nice and ara gets some nice
moments to shine and also it this is one
of the better instances of digging into
what it is she does and how and how she
operates a little bit better you know
laying out to this guy who's just been
defeated you know because he's like I'll
make sure you never work again and she
looks and goes that's not how this works
you are now blacklisted you'll never be
able to be with a licensed companion
ever again so I like how it firmly
establishes the the nature of the power
that she wheels in the business that
she's in it's still a little bit at odds
cuz shouldn't this guy have known that
but um you know in terms of getting that
information to the audience it's a
pretty decent way to do it so again this
one's just kind of a mix of elements
that I'm kind of met on and stuff that's
like oh that's fun this is just kind of
middling next up we have trash now this
was the second appearance of I'm gonna
call her Safran she accumulates like
five names over the course of her two
appearances and unfortunately I really
wish they had left her one appearance
that you'll notice we haven't talked
about her first appearance yet there but
her second appearance is just not as
good sort of already knowing her deal
already knowing what she's like she's
not nearly as intriguing as realizing
she had been playing everybody from the
beginning as opposed to walking and
going yet she's obviously playing
everybody we know this there is still
fun to watch ultimately mal and his
group outsmart her and outwit her and
you know they try and go a little deeper
on her in terms of giving some details
on her background give me some
possibilities of some things in her past
that she would never admit to but just
overall it it's it's a weaker appearance
than her first appearance and for that
this [ __ ] in here number 10 Ariel this
is an episode that if it'd been if it
had had the opportunity to ultimately
pay off properly might have ranked
higher unfortunately it drops a number
of things that either get addressed in a
very hurried fashion later on like in
the movie or don't get addressed at all
like the guys with the blue hands never
gonna see them again I mean if you if
you dig into some of the ancillary
material I think some of the comic books
sort of cover a little bit more about
what their deal was and what was going
on there but you know in terms of the in
terms of the show in terms of the movie
that's never gonna get fully addressed
the stuff that Simon finds out about
River and about what happened to her we
get a little bit of resolution on later
on down the line but that feels like it
wasn't fully paid off
Jane betraying there and trying to turn
them in though the way that played in
himself was good and the way that Matt
went Mountain confronts him and gets him
out into the I'm not even sure if it's a
properly it must be a proper air like
gives him out into the air lock him
won't let him in and it's gonna kill him
and you know Jane asks what are you
gonna tell them about why I'm dead I'm
out and mal says you know I hadn't
thought about it yet and there's this
pause and Jane says make something up
don't tell them what I did and that's
enough formality
give him another chance realizing that
he's not even gonna bother pleading for
his life anymore he he he must feel bad
because he cares about what these people
think of him like in at this point that
is more important to him than living
because he gave up on that already and
it's not it's not a true redemptive
moment Jane Jane is not redeemed in that
moment but it is that believably that
sliver of humanity that mal allows him
to live and it it was a really fine line
to walk because we've seen mal kill
people for not much so for him to allow
Jane to live after having done this that
ad that had to be that was a razor-thin
line that this show had to walk and it
walked it and it nailed it and even the
stuff that I complained about it's not
bad it's just knowing that there's no
proper payoff or explanation for a lot
of it not fully just kind of leaves you
gone fine number nine serenity the film
not the not the not the two-parter first
episode it's really annoying that I have
to specify that so rewatching the
surrounding film was a very weird
experience because seeing that film in
the theater was one of the best movie
going experiences I ever had I actually
started a preview screening in Boston
and like some of the cast was there I
think I think it was Kaylee and Simon I
can't think of the actors names right
now they were there to introduce the
movie it it was a wonderful
theater-going experience um however the
times that I've revisited since then I
keep finding more and more things that
annoy me first off I I mentioned how in
safe it was almost all Western with no
sci-fi serenity the film swings it
almost entirely in the opposite
direction after we get the one sort of
heist in the beginning it's almost all
sci-fi with no Western and while you
like I said I'm not big on westerns if
you were asked me just straight John
Rose I would watch a sci-fi movie before
I would watch a Western it was the
blending of those two that
like so the fact that this goes that
this doesn't come across like sci-fi
Western but instead sci-fi with cowboy
style characters in it it loses some of
the flavor of the show which I otherwise
really love I've got mixed feelings
about the operative I love true Hotel
Ejiofor in the part is actually the
first thing I ever saw him in and he's
really really good in it
but I've got I'm actually gonna end up
doing a separate video about my problems
with him so that that'll be a little bit
done why so I won't dwell on that but he
is very good in the part and the the
resolution of certain things works well
enough I don't like the Reavers being
explained I think they are way scarier
when we didn't know where they came from
and now that we've know oh they were
just created by that and now we've left
we know what they are like the idea that
the only explanation we have no idea
what the Reavers are and I mean we know
they're people it's not like they're
aliens but the fact that the only
possibility that anyone can think of was
they saw the edge of space and just went
mad and no one can be sure whether or
not that's even what happened that
worked that was terrifying and
especially with some of the stuff we saw
in episodes I have yet to get to on this
list
that that really did work for me and so
getting an actual explanation is like oh
well this isn't nearly as enticing to me
I don't think explaining the Reavers
makes them more interesting or makes
them scarier more compelling or really
anything more than they were before we
had them explained and I'm also not sure
the timeline makes any sense because the
way this movie lays it out they only
would have been around for what 15 20
years tops and it seems weird that like
the Reavers have been around for
probably about as long as simon's been
alive it feels like they should have
been around longer than that
I don't know but so there's a mix of
things but you know for the complaints I
just had and wash em hmm
but there is a lot of gray stuff there's
fantastic dialogue there's awesome
action scenes in this there's some
really good character moments I love
book and mal talking about by the fire
um there's some terrific action scenes I
really do love um rivers action seems
like just does the ballet of death is
this is what it is in my head and I love
that and that's great it's so there is
there's a lot of really good stuff in
this movie but there's also a fair
amount of stuff that really irks me so I
can't go higher than this number eight
hour mrs. Reynolds the first time that
we saw a Safran and yet she works a lot
better here she is I think it's such a
great character here in terms of when
the turn comes and and you realize that
she was not which he was pretending to
be at all and just watching her play
character after character actor
character first she gets mouth then she
tries for watch and it doesn't worry she
just knocks him out and my favorite
though is they're trying to put the foot
of the Mojo the whammy on to Inara and
an hour of figuring you know going along
and then just you know something happens
like an alarm goes off or something and
she just looks at her and goes you're
good yes so are you who are you where'd
you learn that I think oh I love that
it's so good and she's just fun like
that there were a number of villains or
obstacle characters she's the most she's
the most fun by far in my my at least in
this in this appearance and she's yeah
this is just a great little kind of con
artist II kind of kind of story and I
really enjoy it number seven war stories
so this is where now and wash get
abducted by Niska and tortured it does a
real good job of showing the strength of
the bond between some of these
characters the bond between a wash and
mouth about the bond between mal and Zoe
between wash and Zoey I mean it's best
summed up I think by you know Zoey
talking with Niska and him you're doing
this big build-up and you know he's
gonna go like you can only pick one of
them and she doesn't even wait for him
to finish he just points at Washington
says him I mean that's it that's perfect
and you know then then going in the
rescue and the rescue was really cool
and then River has an awesome moment
where she um looks out and just sees the
the guys there that and she just picks
up a gun doesn't even look ping and she
doesn't even seem to realize what it was
she did and it's a that's one of the
better sort of seeds planted about what
she's capable of and I love that a lot
that really works moving forward and
there's so much like so like you often
get in the show there's some great lines
like you've got book you know gearing up
and so it doesn't doesn't the good book
have a few things to say about the
subject of murder murder and yes very
specific things it is however much more
vague on the subject of kneecaps hey I
love this guy and it's it's intense when
it needs to be intense it's it's an
exciting rescue and it's when it gets to
that point it is properly emotional
between Zoey and wash and then it's
funny towards the end when mal very
awkwardly jokingly tries to pay off you
know having said to wash while they were
being tortured well I think I need to
sleep with your wife because there's
obviously tension that needs to be
released so all that and some laughs
good stuff number six the message so
this one is the one where Zoey and
mouths old war buddy shows up they think
he's dead he's not he's actually a mule
and how that all plays out and that one
does that one does a good job of
relaying the lingering damage that the
war had on just the people who were
there and that means mal that means Zoey
that means their friend and it does it
in a way that isn't like beating PTSD
over
her head but at the end of the day you
know in some ways they you know they
didn't die in the war but some ways they
didn't really survive not not as the
people that they were before it ended
and this episode does a pretty good job
of illustrating that well the same time
keeping things moving along with kind of
a chase hunt story
and you know the guy I don't know the
actor's name he appeared on Angel 2 and
actually he was in Buffy he would he was
he was one of the the trifecta key
actors he appeared in all three and
anyone he was good in all three and he
always in all three appearances he did
that kind of you're drawn to him and you
like him but you're like you're also
you're not good like not in a fun spike
way but in a you just damaged aren't you
and you know in some cases of some of
his appearances and Whedon's alter shows
that that sort of played out a little
bit later but he was real good for that
vibe it was real good for this part and
I think like I said it just shows the
that that lingering damage and even as
you're bonding with the people who are
there with you it brings out the bad of
what it was you lived through number
five objects in space last episode of
the show before it was Cannes well it
had already been cancelled before this
thing didn't even air initially but last
episode of the show before we got the
movie so this one is Jubal Early and I
described in my ten words segment um
that he was the the rough draft of the
operative and I feel like he was in some
ways this slightly off a slightly
unusual guy who's really capable at what
he does
they do kind of go about their things
very different but I like early as a
character and he I feel like there might
have been at the lake house
few things that could have been handled
a little bit better like I think I think
they kind of tipped a hand to how
unpleasant he was a little too early
like when out of nowhere he says to
Kaylee have you ever been raped which is
really uncomfortable oh it is probably
supposed to be don't get me wrong
but I think it might have it might have
played even a little better if we if we
didn't really see start to see that that
nastiness come out until he was getting
more frustrated and not being able to
find River and River starts tormenting
him over the speakers but you know
battling that pick aside he's a
fascinating character he's really well
played he's really he's just weird it's
just a weird guy who says weird things
and but at the same time is so good at
what he does that it's a really funky
balance so he's interesting what River
does to deal with this guy is
interesting it just it just plays really
well for something that has a ton of
focus on a villain who had not appeared
before so he's not a recurring villain
he's a one-timer this had a really
interesting focal point and it makes for
a fascinating episode that also feels
like a good solid send-off for the show
in a lot of ways because it feels like
we get our little moments with each one
of these characters as they try and deal
with just the stuff they keep running
into or keeps finding them number four
the Train job so after the much longer
serenity pilot episode was presented to
Fox they basically said yeah can you do
the same thing in half the time and thus
the Train job which does reiterate a lot
of the same points that that first story
did but does it add a much faster pace
and mm it's a lot of fun like I like the
slower moments of Firefly I like the
more contemplative moments but this is a
rip-roaring fun episode and that's no
bad thing I enjoy that a lot I love
above the end where when this goes
henchmen Mao's trying to give him the
money back say look telescope we
couldn't do it and everything's square
and the guys you know stands up he's
like I will hunt you down me like oh is
this guy gonna be a recurring villain
Mouse just like huh kicks him and me get
sucked into the intake of of serenity
and I oh I guess he's not gonna be
recurring again just making the point
about mouths like if you are in his way
and you're not gonna move he will move
you if I move you I mean kill you so
like that I mean that ending moment but
all the stuff prior to that was was
really cool and really fun because we
get you know the nature their nature as
criminals what they're willing to do
they're always willing to steal from the
Alliance but when they realize who this
is actually hurting they're like ah crap
we don't have it in our hearts to
actually do this because we make our
living as criminals but we're not bad
people most of them aren't at any rate
and so and like all that information
that was in the much longer actual first
episode of the show does all appear in
here just in a more compressed timeline
and being more compressed and more
condensed into short time doesn't
actually sacrifice all that much is
pretty impressive number three out of
gas I wasn't kidding when I did the the
10-word segment on this I watching this
is really tense and despite the fact
that like you should know there's no bay
mal doesn't live through this it really
does feel like oh my god we're gonna
watch him die it it ratchets it up by
steps as it goes along really really
well and just the things that keep going
we're on and just and just the slow oh
my god what is next what now and as he's
sending everyone off and we get and we
get the flash bags and we get our first
look at these berries people who and how
they found their way onto the ship the
ones who we didn't already see their
first mirror so we get to find out how
Kaylee got there how wash got there
NRA's first encounter with mal which I
don't love I mentioned it already but
that's kind of really my only sticking
point with this episode and then then
Jane basically just buying the guy who
track who was paid to track you down cuz
he made him a better offer yeah that's
uh that's Jane makes total sense and
injured intermingling what was by and
large you know enjoyable light like oh
good memories of how these people came
onto the ship with the ship is dead
space and the captain is dying the
juxtaposition of that works really
really well and the points at which it
cuts from one to the other all work
terrifically it's just a it's just a
really well-balanced episode for what
it's trying to do everything just feeds
into the different elements and just
makes it great
number two bushwhacked funny thing I did
a I did a preliminary list of rankings
of episodes based off my memory before I
went back in and we watched these and I
figured I would rewatch the first few I
just to make sure it was what I
remembered now bushwhacked is a fairly
early I think essentially the third
episode and I had that fairly low on my
preliminary list and then I watch them
like why did I have a solo this is great
um and which made me then watch the
entire rest the saiyans like cuz
obviously my memory is not what it
should be um in terms of all this so man
so this is the episode where they pick
up a survivor of a river attack he saw
the worst that humanity could possibly
be and it broke him and the fear that
these people have of what it was that he
encountered what it was that he is now
trying to emulate and the tension the
way it shot the pacing of it it is
unnerving
it is disquieting it if it feels like
something out of the Alien franchise and
but it doesn't involve creature it
doesn't involve the unknown it doesn't
involve you know an alien monster it's
just a man a man who saw and survived
things that no one should see if they do
see them they should not survive it and
what happens to him to people put into
that situation and just the way
everything is built up in design in
terms of like laying out the mythology
of the Reapers like what the stories
that people who have who live in fear of
them tell each other to try and
understand what this could possibly be I
really really like this episode but if
you've been paying attention and I've
been doing good old-fashioned process of
elimination then you know that my number
one episode up Firefly is serenity V
two-part pilot first episode of this
show I was sold I loved it I loved the
opening like with a big thrilling yeehaw
let's go fight you know keep the troops
upbeat opening the thing goes to such
melancholy as the slow music kicks in
and this kid that seconds ago mal had
been reassuring that they were gonna
live because they are too young and too
pretty to die and this kid standing next
to him just gets gunned down and now you
don't know if he doesn't notice or if he
didn't see her if he can't process it
because he's just staring out at defeat
because he believed in and so from that
opening you immediately get you know
both that mal did not used to be this
jaded but also why he
in a way that is much better than any
you know full flashback episode or
extended story of him telling people
stuff around the dinner table the this
opening communicates that so well and
then we get we get every character it's
such a great introduction because we've
got you know as always part of that
initial thing but then we've got watch
with his dinosaurs curse curse your
inevitable betrayal and oh man I love
wash so much and and you know Kaylee you
know so in love with the ship and
talking to it and and getting real upset
if anyone bad-mouths it and you know
Simon being all cagey River just being
out of it
Jane you know with these great lines
like oh you know the when when he says
to mal you know I didn't portray you
because the money wasn't good enough and
mouses what if what about when it is and
Jane goes well that'll be a very
interesting day and getting a sense on
their dynamic we got badger and I like
badger a lot he's a lot of fun the just
the the time with which this is able to
take things because it is a two-parter
it's a double length episode
I love the introductions of all these
characters I love the feel of it I love
the music in it I I feel like this tells
you what this show is more than any
other single episode does and the fact
that it is able to be the pilot be the
episode that has to establish everything
that has to establish these people this
world the situation all of it but it
does it in a way that doesn't feel
perfunctory it doesn't feel like it yeah
yeah yeah yeah can you establish it so
we can actually get to a good story it's
it's the whole package as far as I'm
concerned and to me that makes it the
best episode of Firefly that was ever
made so those are my thoughts that's my
list that's my ranking plus your little
stuff down
the front with the 10-word stuff hope
you had fun what are your thoughts on
Firefly how would you rank it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
all the stuff to do such as like and
subscribe support me on patreon if you
like my stuff the links for all that
stuff and more down in the description
so until next time this council is
adjourned